what's your thoughts on the new redfall
info that came out I mean I think bran
hit it right on the nail on the head
like it's they've done a disservice to
this game up until this point because
none of this information has come out
through their own channels and I think
for a game like this you can be
secretive about a game that like that's
a known quantity already that people
have expectations for you you can't
really do it with this you really need
to give this game all the spotlight that
it kind of needs in order for people to
understand what it is so if you look at
like a death Loop coming from Arcane
death Loop was the simplification of
immersive Sim elements to try to make it
more palatable to more people this is
taking that and saying okay we're going
to take the immersive sin we're taking
to take everything that we learn from
making games like System Shock and prey
and thief and we're gonna blow it up and
give you a world the size of Far Cry and
let you play in this space
while eliminating the UV softness of it
of opening